[Musique]
les gens se sont réunis ici
la manifestation avait commencé dans les
quartiers sur la colline il y avait
entre 15 et 20 mille personnes un
régiment de parachutistes a suivi les
gens jusqu'ici ils ont commencé à tirer
sur la foule
en 1972 la ville nord-irlandaise de
derry a été le théâtre du bloody sunday
une manifestation pour les droits
civiques de la minorité catholique est
réprimée dans le sang par l'armée
britannique
quatorze personnes sont tuées john kelly
participé à la manifestation avec son
frère ici que le bloody sunday a eu lieu
et mon frère michael est mort ce jour-là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
déry ville symbole du conflit entre
londres et les nationalistes irlandais
et surtout toute proche de la frontière
avec la république d'irlande
de l'autre côté du fleuve
c'est le comté de donegal en république
d'irlande par boîte on a une meilleure
vue comme vous voyez on est vraiment
tout proche
chez les bryson on est éleveur de père
en fils depuis un siècle
kevin élève des bovins à viande des deux
côtés de la frontière
il a 2 170 vaches au royaume-uni 130 en
république d'irlande
pour l'instant toutes ses vaches sont
européennes nous arrivons à la frontière
vous voyez ces panneaux voilà c'est ici
nous voilà en république d'irlande
comme vous voyez la route est libre il
n'y a aucun heurt depuis les accords de
paix de 1998
on circule librement entre des rideaux
n'égale une frontière invisible que cet
éleveur travers cinq à dix fois par
semaine mais kevin se souvient de
l'époque où la démarcation entre les
deux irlande et est lourdement gardé par
des soldats britanniques
ici c'était une zone fortifiée votre
véhicule était arrêté et vous pouviez
être retenu pendant une heure deux
heures
la perspective du bric site ravive de
mauvais souvenirs chez kevin dyson le
rétablissement de la frontière couperet
son exploitation en 2nd frontières et
des contrôles entraînerait des
ralentissements et des coûts et sur le
plan politique cela créera des divisions
là où l'on ne devrait pas y en avoir un
bébé
l'histoire nous enseigne que les
divisions ce n'est pas un hacker
après le break site kevin devra faire
une croix sur deux tiers des aides
européennes qu'il perçoit aujourd'hui à
delhi
tout le monde redoute l'impact
économique du rétablissement de la
frontière à l'image de gavin câline cet
entrepreneur a racheté une imprimerie en
2004 il emploie aujourd'hui 40 personnes
[Musique]
il y à 18 mois
kevin a investi près d'un million
d'euros dans cette imprimante ultra
modernes fabriquées au danemark
si on devait acheter cette machine en
étant à l'extérieur de l'union
européenne les taxes à l'import la
rendrait sans doute trop cher pour eux
mais aujourd'hui personne ne fabriquent
ce type de machine
gavin apporte toute sa matière première
de l'union européenne et réalise 40% de
son chiffre d'affaires avec la
république d'irlande
le problème c'est l'incertitude
y aura-t-il une frontière des contrôles
douaniers les marchandises pour hôtels
circuler librement
nous ne savons pas certains de nos
clients en république d'irlande envisage
de ne plus fournir au royaume uni mais
plutôt de se tourner vers des
fournisseurs dans l'union européenne
oui mais nous pourrions envisager de
délocaliser une partie de l'activité en
république d'irlande
ce qui est sûr c'est que le temps nous
est compté
gavin ignore à quoi ressemblera la
frontière après le break site
certains évoquent même le maintien de
l'irlande du nord dans le marché unique
mais pour ce député du parti unioniste
qui a fait campagne pour la sortie de
l'europe c'est hors de question
ses 14 derniers mois on a agité beaucoup
de peur nous devons dépasser cela et
travailler ensemble
l'irlande du nord a traversé beaucoup
d'épreuves ces quarante dernières années
en termes de violence et de terrorisme
et pourtant nos entreprises ont tenu le
cap le royaume uni est entré unis dans
lieux il doit en sortir unis les
nationalistes irlandais plaide quant à
eux pour une réunification des deux
irlande en attendant les européens ont
acté leur refus du retour à une
frontière physique
quitte à remettre en question
l'intégrité territoriale du royaume uni
[Musique]
tous